hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
injustice to has just released and it's
got me thinking about superhero games
the Batman Arkham series
Lego Marvel The Punisher and the smash
hit that was spider-man and the x-men on
the Super Nintendo
[Music]
okay it was terrible but I liked it
anyway before I get sidetracked any
further here are eight superhero filled
video games coming soon
let's start off with Marvel's attempt to
invade the MMO space in Marvel heroes
Omega so if you're a PC gamer you
already know about this one as it was
released back in 2013 in an attempt to
faceoff with DC Universe Online but he
never really got the exposure you'd
expect well the time has come for ps4
and Xbox users to get their grubby hands
on this one you can sign up for the ps4
beta right now and it will be free to
play when the final release is made
available this is an action RPG where
you'll fill the boots of your favorite
superheroes leveling their stats and
attributes to fight the way you want
that could be ranged attacks for Hawkeye
or up close and personal like Deadpool
of Batman is DC isn't it which is better
anyway Marvel or DC shout out your
allegiance below
have you heard of the Avengers project
well it's so early on in development
that all we have is a teaser trailer
lasting less than a minute in it we see
the wreckage of the Avengers Iron Man's
armed caps shield dr. banners glasses
and Thor's hammer you know the hammer
the one with the unpronounceable name
known him near me on mini era yeah
nailed it before what's interesting
about the Avengers project is who make
it Crystal Dynamics the longtime
developers of the award-winning Tomb
Raider series here in collab with the
Deus Ex developer I - Montreal that's a
triple threat of creativity there and I
for one cannot wait to see what they
produce we'll be waiting a while as the
project will not be shown again until
2018 there is a hash tag that goes along
with the trailer which is reassemble
what could that mean please let me know
your thoughts another Marvel influenced
fighter it's on its way in the shape of
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite there's been
a few of these in the past and although
they lack the finesse of say Tekken they
still offer something which no other
fighter cannot Megaman and Ryu beating
up Iron Man
things get even more brilliantly messed
up the sort of the story mode want to
see chun-li teaming up with the Avengers
well she's here spinning star kicking
the [ __ ] out of everyone she meets and
look even Chris Redfield from Resident
Evil is here Marvel vs. Capcom is a
truly ridiculous mashup which improves
every iteration are you grabbing this
one for me it's even this of Tekken 7
and I think Tekken 7 has the edge what
about agents of mayhem this one isn't
linked to Marvel or DC which is pretty
hard to find in this day and age well
agents of mayhem is set in the photo
universe of states row that's a quote by
the way I never bother swear this one is
good versus evil on an intergalactic
scale it's a squad shooter with 12
playable characters and is essentially a
bullet storm of pandemonium this game
will now certainly yield an 18 rating
just for its language alone in fact
you'll know an agents of mayhem fan from
a mile away as all they seem to shout is
if storyline and character development
is what you want from your superheroes
and check out the guardians of the
galaxy from telltale I'm sure you
already know about all the telltale
games that are out there but if you
don't this is an interactive story with
multiple options and variations to each
and every part of the story it doesn't
have the film likenesses which can put
some newcomers to the franchise off but
if you want to know what happened when
the Guardians went up against Thanos
then check it out now
[Music]
keep in mind this is episodic and a new
episode is released each month
culminating in the fifth and final
chapter another game where you play as a
guardian of the galaxy is destiny - this
is going to be huge and you will be
overexposed in no time it's a
first-person shooter with some
third-person elements the first destiny
game was criticized massively for its
frankly non-existent story what over the
past three years the storytelling has
improved massively and the gunplay is
almost perfect consoles if you buy this
one you'll be collecting loot for years
and that sounds fantastic to me if
you're getting this on ps4 please add me
and let's rate together I'll throw my
gamertag in the description below go
insomniac spider-man ps4 that's a
working title by the way is next on the
list and puts us in the shoes of Peter
Parker and his web slinging alter-ego
one questions on your mind will it be as
good as the snez version
we'll know it's quality soon enough but
Sony are keeping a tight leash on this
one we are still waiting to find out
what criminals and supervillains will be
hunting down but hopefully this one will
play similarly to the Batman Arkham
series but with less depressing sites by
the way I think Peter Parker is wasted
as a photojournalist he should be a web
designer
I love the puns I love the puns everyone
loves the puns finally Star Wars
Battlefront 2 are they super heroes they
have magic swords they can use
telekinesis and they have mind
controlling powers and fight to save the
galaxy - so yeah these are Super Heroes
Battlefront 2 is looking damn good at
this early stage and all hovels fighting
for the dark side across 30 years of
action it will pick up at the end of
Return of the Jedi and it will go all
the way through until the force awakens
I have a video which breaks down what to
expect in battlefront 2 so I'll link it
at the end of this video if you are
interested but that's it that's 8
superhero filled video games coming to
us very soon what floats your boat and
who would win in a fight between Marvel
and DC my money's on Marvel and a crappy
superhero ever man ape sounds terrible
it man ape I'm Adam from PlayStation
grenade please give us a like if you
think this video is worth it I'll see
you next time